hi how y'all doing my name's Greg Alba
and I'm John we're gonna watch the
trailer today for a movie called brings
down now brimstone his movie Silent Hill
stars Kit Harington a game of the round
it's too personally I think it's the ice
God named Guy Pearce Oh got pears I know
that old got pears from [ __ ] lockout
radar for brutal spell not a bottle in
strong sexual content wise a lot of our
graphic nudity in 279 beware of false
prophets come to you in sheep's clothing
the love was mainly they are ravening
wolves
Jesus is the shepherd who protects you
from those walls and I nice dog the
sheepdog that get the Lambs back on
track when they stray off the path some
of you have strayed yeah
beautiful Reverend says he's here to
shake you back where he came from
I know you're there I know you can hear
me you may have my tongue but there is
nothing wrong with your ears
[Music]
do you know why I'm here
[Music]
I'm here to punish you whoa it's the
same whoa
[Music]
ain't never gonna stop is he I've seen
your mother she's the kind of person
that turns the other cheek be like her
[Music]
never leave your loved ones at home you
should not it's by now
Oh Martin cool dude everybody looks
awesome it looks pretty intense man okay
yeah it's like the which meets don't say
anything John I know this the which
meets the first half of the trailer
reminding me of Black Snake Moan the
Winx flash like some of them it looks
like he's straight-up like has him and
James and [ __ ] yeah but the punishment
and stuff because for a hot second I
thought it was gonna become Fifty Shades
of Grey in the Old West
it kind of has like just a moment when
she had that like lace I blindfold on he
was like you have to wake her right
person you pervert of course you're mine
yeah I love those movies course you're
my shades are disgusting her Valentine's
Day that's why I love you 2008 yeah
thank you
what I like about it cuz it still looks
and semi feels like a Western film like
a slow-moving Western but it kind of has
that haunting religious Christian
element yeah thing out of like oh the
witch time period which in like looking
like the witches anyway you can see like
another side where the West they have
Western [ __ ] going on you know so having
that specific kind of time period so
it's like a western room taking
Christianity to that you know kind of
darker extreme yeah what if you got
really dark ritual' Western you know
like a super gay super dark creature I
think it looks cool it looks really
meaning Guy Pearce looks like he's gonna
give a memorable villainous role that's
for sure
Guy Pearce looks awesome the thing I'm
concerned about what this is where's Kit
Harington he's gonna die early that's
why I says and Kit Harington he's gonna
die er okay or not be in it very much
super busy filming Game of Thrones yeah
I was gonna say like he's barely in this
trailer and when he is like they quickly
cut away from
well yeah he's barely any other using
him for marketing it says and Kit
Harington he's gonna die early
probably some motivation for like Dakota
Fanning or some [ __ ] oh yeah Dakota
Fanning yeah prostitute yeah good for
her yeah good for her
I'm not gonna say yeah I would buy her
or not if she was a real prostitute that
is wrong but when the camera's not
rolling maybe I'll answer the question
for John okay yeah yeah cuz I want to
know for my own personal benefit then
you get to eat it up the cinematography
looks excellent isn't this guy that they
show this is a man girl's name in West
world the actress Evan Rachel Wood is
that Evan Rachel what's dad I was
thinking that I can't tell quite but it
looks like 107 it looks like the guy
played Evan Rachel Wood so father oh
yeah it was the Red Queen the other
actress in yeah that girl oh yeah yeah
look John that's what I call good eye
that's what you call it good eye
yeah cuz for a second I thought it was
Jennifer Connelly John please you got to
start paying Oh repo mint we're going on
the Schmo down again man oh if you're
gonna Karras you got to be able to know
a [ __ ] visual Wade geez Jesus shout
out to Jennifer Connelly anyway but the
code of Fanny looks like she's probably
gonna kill Guy Pearce by the end of this
movie like it looks pretty heavy man
this looks pretty intense
I imagine kit harington's probably gonna
play like a temporary potential hero
yeah who will probably die he will
perish and then leaving only Dakota
Fanning to fend for herself
Dakota Fanning's kind of as weak or sort
of vulnerable character who eventually
turns into [ __ ] Ripley ha ha
kills Guy Pearce yeah Ripley Thomason I
could see it going down that way but
this looks like a haunting religious
western yeah yeah well I think that's a
cool [ __ ] blend well that's a
prominent part of you know in old
western societies like you know the
preacher you know like Oh a new preacher
role it's usually a character or
something but not where it's like he's
punishing the people that live in this
town because a lot of these people are
dedicated Christian yeah dark religious
Western is a cool way to go I think it's
about
about time I think in this day and age
with a show starring Jude Law's a
corrupt Pope I can get away with this
oh I mean The DaVinci Code yeah well
question all-around spotlight this is
all a big setup because guy Pearce's
character is actually you know like 300
years old at this time and he's gonna be
the villain in the next Vinci codes this
is just an origin story for his tale not
every movie needs to connect John I know
guy pierced though I'm happy that he's
getting a role that's not like a million
years old age makeup and Prometheus good
reference a good reference that's the
last time I like really remember seeing
no dude he was in LA Confidential right
I like Edmund Exley came out like two
years ago yeah 2014 oh my god made the
makeup on and looks great cuz he looked
like really like it more natural young
self in LA Confidential yeah I'm in two
years he looks a lot older hey it was
amazing what a haircut and some glasses
will do for you Clark Wayne alright guys
what do you think of the brimstone
trailers a good title
are you excited do you believe in
religion put all your religious comments
down below I notice they make for only
positive commentary on YouTube subscribe
to the real rejects John has a lot of
social media stuff that you just go to
the description box and choose whichever
one you want to click on I want to give
a shout out to a hot topic oh yeah you
guys used to be way cooler what happened
to your store you look like a place
designed for like thirteen year old
normal girls haha like kids I don't want
my kids hanging around should we go to